بدلاً من سحب أرنب من القبعة ،
أخرج واحدًا من حريق غابات في كاليفورنيا
حدث على الطريق السريع 1 عندما
نزل هذا الرجل المجهول من سيارته
لمحاولة إنقاذ أرنب مذعور ،
بدا أن الرجل مذعور وهو يشير بجنون
وهو يشاهد الأرنب يتجه  في
ألسنة اللهب عمليا توسل إليه ليأتي
إليه أخيرًا وهو يركع على ركبتيه ويصل إلى الأرنب البري الذي تمكن أخيرًا من الحصول عليه ، وبدأت
الجوائز على
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي تتكاثر مثل
الأرانب ومثلما
استعاد إيماني بالإنسانية في  تغريدة نموذجية
من الصفر إلى البكاء في النقطة الثانية بعد
قراءة أخرى تغريدة أخرى نيابة
عن حيواناتهم الأليفة يوافق أرنبنا وكيتي
على هذا الشاب كان هناك
أحيانًا حيوانات برية لا
تحتاج إلى الإنقاذ من الحرائق جادل
كاتب لسرد قائلا:  كان من الممكن أن
يكون الرجل قد أصيب وكذلك أي شخص
كان عليه أن يأتي لإنقاذه
ولكن معظم الأرانب التي تم تكريمها تحتاج إلى
أبطال أيضًا فقد فازوا في هذا الرجل الذي
أضاف إلى الهالة.  حول هذا الرجل
هو حقيقة أنه رفض
طلب المصور لإجراء مقابلة على الكاميرا
كما قال أحد الملصقات وأنه
لا يريد أن يكون أمام الكاميرا في لوس أنجلوس ، من
الواضح أن هذا هو يسوع نفسه
يرتدي سروالًا قصيرًا وقلنسوة جين موس سي إن إن نيويورك